>> So we actually going to
explore this idea of labels,
that a mandatory access control
policy would use in a DOD,
Department of Defense
kind of environment.
A little bit more by
looking at some examples.
So information is going to
have classification and
users going to have clearances, okay?
So the highest sensitivity
typically is top secret,
that's the innermost one then secret,
confidential and
going out we have this unclassified we
said this information anyone can see.
So most sensitive,
least sensitive, this is.
We said, the level at which
has somebody is cleared or
the classification
level of the document.
So we said label is going to
be a sensitivity level.
So for example,
it could be top secret here and
a compartment that describes what kind
of data is contained in the document.
So are we going to, let's say look at
documents one, that is top secret.
And let's say these documents
have information about
various arm stock piles.
So this document let us talks about
nuclear and chemical weapons.
You hear about them in the news, so
this is clearly extremely sensitive.
So we going to say
that is top secret and
the document contains information about
both nuclear and chemical weapons.
We have another document that
has information about let's say
conventional.
So maybe it's sensitive but
it's a notch below.
So let's say this is only secret.
So we have two labels here.
L 1, L 1 sensitivity level it's TS
comma the compartment is nuclear,
comma chemical.
Remember this compartment
here looks like a set, okay?
So their document may pertain
to multiple topics or areas.
Each one of them could be in this and
that's the description of
the document using the set
of terms that we have here.
So L1 is (TS comma ).
L2 is secret (S comma {nuclear,
conventional}).
Using these labels L1 and L2, we're
actually going to be able to decide
axis control in the end comes
to being able to read and
write documents because that's
what you do to files or documents.
So we actually, when disclosure or
confidentiality is an issue.
There is a model, Bell and
La Padula model or BLP model
that makes use of labels exactly like
the L1 and L2 that we have here.
And actually the model is defined by
a set of rules that tell you when,
based on these labels,
you can read or write.
But implementation of
the mandatory access control,
is always going to require
some kind of labels.